obrigada vocês sabiam que existe uma
tecnologia capaz de transformar o
cérebro humano em apenas oito semanas
é uma tecnologia não invasiva acessível
a todos nós
milenar e completamente atual
a meditação e foi essa tecnologia que
inspirou a criação do edital na rua um
movimento que surgiu no brasil e que
inesperadamente se espalhou por todos os
continentes e esse grande movimento
internacional surgiu com uma simples
ideia e muita paixão no começo de 2017
eu estava sim completamente encantada
com os benefícios que eu via que a
meditação trazer pra mim as pessoas ao
meu redor e para a centena de pessoas
que eu tive a oportunidade de ensinar e
de acompanhar e mv um desejo assim muito
forte de que mais pessoas pudessem
experimentar isso de que mais pessoas
pudessem experimentar essa sensação de
interesa de empoderamento e de
serenidade que a meditação trás e foi
com esse desejo que eu comecei a
conversar com as amigas ea gente começou
com mais pessoas e começou a criar um
encontro na assim a ideia era organizar
um encontro aberto que o início as
pessoas para meditar junto em espaços
públicos que fosse totalmente inclusivo
na gratuito
desvinculado de qualquer prática
específica se você quiser simplesmente
fechar o olho se quiser melhorar se
quiser praticar qualquer força técnica
de conexão ea gente começou a conversar
então a criar criou o nome medita na rua
a gente criou um banner né assim a
identidade visual um banner bonitão que
a gente pintura no lugar que convida as
pessoas para chegar junto
o formato na então ficou claro pra gente
que ia ser 20 minutos de meditação com
os olhos fechados
é quase um flash
chamou de meditação a gente chega tem
uma acolhe as pessoas têm uma mensagem
de abertura que é um pouco que dá o tom
do encontro
e aí a gente faz os olhos por 20 minutos
então quando ele estava com tudo isso
desenhado a gente então jô resolveu
colocar no facebook um convite para quem
quisesse participar junto com a gente
então nesse momento ea gente tinha
combinado uma data
e nessa data yang ailun acontecer
encontros de meditação coletiva em
lugares públicos em três cidades são
paulo brasília e goiânia
para a nossa surpresa hora que a gente
colocou isso no face começou a viralizar
ea cada dia aparecem nas cidades
querendo isso é parte do encontro também
levar a medida na roupa o seu lugar como
eu participo como eu me envolvo também
quero fazer isso aqui ea gente foi
acolhendo então todas as pessoas nascem
pessoas que eu nem sei como ficaram
sabendo eu não faço ideia até hoje assim
é a grande maioria nem conhecia
pessoalmente mas a gente foi acolhendo e
se estruturando para dar conta dessa
demanda que a gente preparou um passo a
passo com dicas de como se preparar
antes como acolher as pessoas de deixar
espaços vazios para que as pessoas se
sentam se sintam convidadas a chegar e
realize mandava release para a imprensa
a arte do banner atirar a camiseta e
cada dia chegando nova cidade nova
cidade nova cidade
de repente foi cara aquele encontro de
amigos virou um movimento e que estava
grande no brasil foi bom então sei lá
provavelmente unum convida gente de
outros países também então falei com um
amigo da argentina uma amiga da
inglaterra risca da argentina falou com
venezuela méxico bom
três semanas depois chegou o dia do
encontro 11 de junho de 2017 e fomos
milhares de pessoas meditando juntas
simultaneamente em 61 cidades de oito
países
assim totalmente inesperado nem assim
foi muito bonito ver assim
quantas pessoas queriam empreender pela
paz
quantas pessoas queriam
antes de transformação da sua realidade
ea hora que aparece na um convite com um
caminho assim vamos lá vamos junto às
pessoas se jogaram na assim a gente tem
anfitriões do medina na rua ficariam
essa pessoa que escolhe organizar a
meditar na rua na sociedade a gente
tenha opiniões que são jovens
universitários
dona de casa aposentada o empreendedor
social donos de negócios pessoas de
diferentes crenças religiões idades né
assim é super bonito muito rico muito
heterogêneo e também muito que me marcou
muito foi ver a esse podendo brasileira
sem essa paixão do brasileiro de de
fazer junto né assim de querer
transformar a realidade porque foi
porque foi forte aqui que motivou a
abrir para outros países
e aí então a gente teve assim relatos
bem lindo desse primeiro encontro assim
teve medita na rua no parque na praia na
avenida paulista
numa praça não é assim no bairro calor
no nordeste
no frio da noruega na chuva na ilha de
manhattan teve país que eu descobri que
existia porque se inscreveu no
meditarrâneo foi roni e assim foi foi
muito impressionante e as pessoas
relatos assim as pessoas falam da nossa
teve gente que nunca tinha meditado e
que foi pela primeira vez e teve uma
baita experiência assim em são paulo
teve um jovem americano e tinha 18 anos
e ele foi porque a mãe ea avó foram ea
ele foi titular no nem entendeu na
mensagem de abertura nada mas cento e
fechou o olho e depois ele veio falar
assim
eu nem sabia o que era meditação mas eu
tive uma experiência transformadora e
quis levar a camiseta do edital ou
estados unidos não teve pessoa super
experiente que meditam há muitos anos e
que falaram que sentir uma conexão que
eles nunca tinha sentido antes de sentir
conectada consigo mesmo disse chico
conexão com aquelas pessoas que estavam
sentadas ali meditando junto com as
pessoas que estavam passando com as
milhares de pessoas estão acreditando ao
mesmo tempo teve uma participante que
também já acredita muito
anos e que fala assim não se sentir uma
sensação de expansão que foi crescendo
depois do encontro que perdurou em mim
por semana e aí as pessoas quer mais nem
assim quando o próximo quando vai ter
mais e e todo mundo nova cidade querendo
chegar então nesses dois anos a gente
fez três encontros globais do edital na
rua já participaram 100 cidades de 18
países nos cinco continentes e mostra
assim sabe que realmente a meditação é
pra todos nós pode ser em qualquer lugar
e não tem idade
em várias cidades as pessoas falaram
assim que eles estavam sentados
meditando e passavam famílias eram as
crianças que puxavam os pais pra sentar
com o grupo e meditar em belo horizonte
foi muito fofa se eles já tinham
terminado a meditação ea estavam lá
conversando assim tal compartilhando a
experiência cubana tinha ficado um pouco
de lado aqui de repente uma menina
estava no ponto de ônibus com a mãe saiu
sozinha
sentou na frente do banco até minha
cruzada assim e fico meditando sozinhas
até a mãe chamar que o ônibus tinha
chegada e eu percebi que essa geração já
vem com esse tipinho dentro neto eles é
muito fácil e assim a teve uma história
assim que a nossa que me marcou assim
que eu acho que simboliza esse poder que
quando um grupo de pessoas se junta para
meditar juntas em que se transforma não
apenas a gente mas também o entorno é
isso aconteceu em brighton na inglaterra
eles eram 12 pessoas estavam ali se
organizando sentando na calçada para
começar a meditar e chega um senhor
descalço na assim tudo cheio precisam
sempre perfeita a meditação israel que a
idéia é sejam bem vindos à nossa que bom
que me falaram que eu tinha que tá aqui
peguei vários ônibus cruzei a cidade
está bem vindo
só que eu não acredito em tudo bem se
ficar com os olhos abertos e anfitriã
claro né não seria super bem vindo eles
não fecharam os olhos meditaram
eles abriram os olhos esse senhor chegou
para a anfitriã olho no olho dela e
falou vocês pararam o tempo e aí ele
contou que a música do público começou a
tocar mais baixo que as pessoas
começaram a caminhar mais devagar e que
mudou toda a interação e volta deles e
aí com todas essas histórias sempre uma
edição foi mostrando eu entendi que a
meditação não apenas uma ferramenta de
transformação pessoal é uma ferramenta
de transformação do coletivo é uma
ferramenta de inovação social
quando a gente fala de sociedades mais
igualitárias mais justas mais pacíficas
a gente tem que falar de indivíduos que
se sentem mais plenos mais empoderadas e
mais em paz
tem uma frase que eu gosto muito que
assim norte pra mim que é bala sem
aquilo em que você foca sua atenção se
fortalece
eu escolhi focar no amor na gentileza na
união na paz pra minha surpresa milhares
de pessoas nos quatro cantos do mundo
fizeram essa mesma escolha
obrigada
hum